- Narrator: You've been bitten!
And, uh-oh, it's venomous.
How long have you got?
Well, that depends on a few factors,
including the potency, dose delivered,
and speed of distribution.
Turns out, not all
venoms act the same way.
Here are the animals
with the fastest acting venom on earth.
First up, spiders.
There are around 40,000 species of spider
and most are venomous.
But, thankfully, only a handful
pose a threat to humans,
including the male
Sydney Funnel-web Spider.
Its venom is 60 times as potent as cyanide
and can kill a human in one to two hours.
The venom attacks the nervous system,
kicking it into overdrive until,
ultimately, it shuts down.
Of course, spiders aren't the only
venomous animals in Australia.
It's home to 20 of the
world's 25 deadliest snakes,
including the Eastern Brown
Snake which is responsible
for the most snakebite
deaths in the country.
Its venom is 8,000 times
stronger than cyanide
and can kill a human in about one hour.
Its venom also attacks
the central nervous system
but, this time, it slows everything down.
And, to top it off, the
venom has a coagulant
that causes the blood in your
veins and arteries to clot.
Between the two, it's
not a good way to go.
Now, at this point, you
might consider switching
your Australian safari to a scuba dive,
just to be on the safe side.
But, venomous animals live
in Australian waters too,
like the Blue-ringed Octopus.
Its venom is 1,000 times
more toxic than cyanide
and it'll bring down a human
in just 20 to 40 minutes.
Bacteria in its saliva makes
an extremely potent neurotoxin
which paralyzes your muscles.
And, once that paralysis
hits your diaphragm
and rib muscles, you
have only a few minutes
before you suffocate to death.
But another marine
animal is even deadlier.
The fastest acting venom on earth
belongs to the Australian
Box Jellyfish, or Sea Wasp.
It's not the most potent venom out there
at 2,000 times stronger than cyanide,
but encounter one of these guys
and you'll be dead in 15 minutes.
That's because their tentacles are covered
with tiny, venom loaded
darts called nematocysts,
which shoot heart-stopping
toxins into the body
wherever they make contact.
All of this sounds pretty
scary but, remember,
you're less likely to
die by venomous spider
than by car crashes and
infection, or disease.
And, it's not like these
animals are after you anyway.
They'd just as well prefer
that you stick to your own habitat.
But, still, be smart,
be respectful, be safe.
Tell us the scariest animal
encounter you've ever had,
and thanks for watching.